you know with reaction fox news
contributor laura trump along with
football legend
uh heisman trophy winner herschel walker
now it's interesting having both of you
on um because i've seen polling on both
of you
happens to be for the same office in two
different states herschel
i have the trafalgar poll uh robert
kihali friend of this program
and he has you beating as senator
warnock
lara trump last poll i saw in terms of
getting the nomination
you were up by a whopping 15 points and
a winner you would win the general
election according to that poll
uh so both of you are in a pretty unique
position
herschel will start with you because
i've already pressured laura enough she
probably hates me right now
as a fox news contributor and friend um
herschel walker are you considering a
run for the u.s senate from the state of
georgia
well i'm honored that they keep uh
saying that if i'm considering it
and as i told everyone guys i'm wearing
my options
but i can promise you this and this is
probably what the poster have seen that
if i run
i'm running to win because right now
what's going on in this country is
absolutely absolutely terrible i believe
in god i believe in country and i
believe in family
and i can tell you all americans are my
family it is sad that people are not
standing up for the law
i believe in law and order i hate to
tell everyone out there this country was
built on that
i'm tired of hearing about black america
white america
asian america uh hispanic america this
is the united states of america
and we got to get back to that we got to
get leaders in washington that believe
in that and that's
that's how we're going to fix this here
do i hear
george's on your mind i don't know it
sounds a little bit like that to me
well georgia is always on my mind it's
been on my mind and uh that's what
people don't realize
just because i was living in texas i you
know i have a lot of stuff there in
georgia
and uh you know and that's why i say i'm
honored that they'll consider me running
for senate but i do have to do all my
due diligence
and uh and see what in the world is
going on and and then i'm gonna i'm
gonna weigh my options and figure this
out
and if you run you're in to win you know
laura i guess that's probably a lot of
trouble
there's no doubt laura i assume in your
case there's a lot of pressure
but it is amazing that you you really
the american people and the people of
north carolina that's your home state
that's where you're born and raised
know you so well they're showing
incredible confidence in you
um that's got to give you reason to
pause
somewhat no
absolutely look i'm so honored i'm so
humbled when i see these polls
um it's it's amazing to see and i
appreciate it so
much and i i'm going to echo there what
herschel said we need
strong leaders we need people in 22 and
24
that have the best interests of the
american people at heart because
you're exactly right hershel what we
have seen happen in america
it's so tragic it's so disturbing we've
got to get
this country back on track so um i love
seeing this polling i'm so honored
obviously as you said my home state i
love it um it is a decision that i am
also weighing um
again nothing to break here on hannity
tonight uh but maybe herschel and i will
come back together and give you our
final decision we'll see
okay it'd be like the final episode of
the apprentice we'll
we'll do a two-hour special you know
both of you touched on something though
this agenda of the democrats
the spending the borders packing the
courts
ending the legislative filibuster
everything that they're proposing i've
never seen anything like it and i've
never been more concerned herschel
and laura uh and laura will let you up
first i've never been concerned about
the direction of the country like i
am now
well it starts at the top it starts
unfortunately with the president right
now joe biden and
there is a total lack of leadership um
it's been very sad to see obviously what
has happened on our southern border the
fact that
that has not been addressed by in any
way shape or form by our vice president
kamala harris who was tasked with that
three plus weeks ago now she hasn't
visited
she hasn't held a press conference about
it um you see
so many people that i think feel very
disturbed and we're only in april
right now joe biden took office january
20th so
if you're upset about the way things are
going now just hold on we haven't even
talked
about what's happening around the world
as it relates to america remember when
donald trump was in office
it was america first we were protected
we were safe
we took care of our country it seems
very different now
so look i think the american people come
2022 are going to be ready for a
significant change
and i think by 24 they're going to be
totally done
with the harris biden biden harris
however they're calling it
uh in the white house herschel will give
you the last word tonight
you see now internationally aggression
by china aggression by russia
aggression by the iranians we have no
idea what north korea is up to
and then look at the economy and and
look at the high taxes that are coming
look at all the regulation look at all
the jobs being lost in the energy sector
for example
well i think people should be very
certain concerned about all this being
the reason why
we was the greatest country in the world
right now we're going to give china an
opportunity to take us over
and i think one thing that we got to do
we got to fight for it we are americans
and if people don't like it and i hate
to say this get out right now we got to
fight for america
i think we got to get leaders in
washington that want to fight for
america because right now we're giving
it away
and i don't want to do that i'm going to
be honest i'm not giving it away i'm
going to fight for it
i'm going to do whatever i can for and
that's the reason i say i'm going to
weigh my fight
my my opportunity here and i want to
thank everyone
in america for it i want to thank
everyone in georgia but i i will let you
know as laura just said you know what
maybe we'll come back and
and give someone some some news and let
them know what's going to be going on
america needs strong leaders that make
promises
and fight to keep them it's not that
complicated
thank you both laura trump thank you
herschel walker thank you come